narry mine de mary surratt avec - drogba
n'est que bonheur qu'une autre couleur
naturelle mais c'est plus dur ces bruits
ne sait plus quand j'ai vu le jour dans
une émission de chez daniela lumbroso
sur ratio lci est alors un moment elle
était interloquée
parce que vous avez dit et je crois que
c'est un peu le coeur du film vous avez
dit être tolérant c'est aimer un raciste
pas parce qu'il est raciste et parce que
c'est un être humain et elle n'a pas
compris il a lancé la pub et je crois
que non mais non mais je veux dire c'est
vrai la compassion c'est ça quand le
pape va pardonner ali agça qui lui a
tiré des balles dans le ventre c'est
pareil bon c'est vrai que moi je cherche
toujours à comprendre ma tête je veux
condamner chez pas fondées souvent la
tolérance et les à sens unique
c'est vrai que c'est mieux si marilyn
par exemple dans le film un moment bon à
lhassa garde du front national c'est
parce qu'elle ait pas d'autres solutions
pour trouver du boulot je dirais c'est
pas parce que les nazis parce qu'elle
est raciste et je sais ce que je trouve
bien dans ce film fait même le pur et
dur moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est savoir
je vais avoir ma soir lui dire comment
il en est arrivé là et comment il en est
arrivé là il ya des départs on a mis
dans des sketches peut passer des heures
à se poser une question à la fin il
répond à cette question et elle achète
son célèbre ou pas ben oui c'est qu'on a
une conviction c'est vrai je crois que
tata ça ouais ou pas ou pas c'est d'être
capable d'envisager le point de vue de
l'autre ou pas c'est diakhaté ya nulle
compliqué qu'on leur disait y avait
quelqu'un qui habiterait journée tous le
compte quels cas on est tous l'étranger
de quelqu'un
enfin bon on sait bien que ça marche
vous dit chez nous bâle est bien quand
j'étais petit palais bien c'était
inconcevable seul remède contre le
cafard c'était de faire le tour du pâté
de maisons c'était marche ou crève
et là vers l'âge de 5 6 ans vous
découvrez que finalement le rire peut
sauver les pires moments
et quand vous êtes à l'arrière de la
voiture voisine que chez vous on a les
détroits donc imaginer de moquette à
côté de moi et moi au milieu
moi je vous le dis vous aviez faire des
tours en voiture j'imagine sa balade on
allait dans la lah montbrison la ola le
village un peu plus petites crêpes au
ciel il répondait voir les amis des
jeunes restaurant et là vous découvrez
en fait que dans la voiture ou dit des
vannes ça fait marrer tout le monde donc
vous dites je me sentais responsable de
leur bonheur à tous oui c'est exactement
ça responsable j'avais cette
responsabilité là il alors à l'époque un
peu comme dans marilyn la marilyn ali
finalement les coûts de joe dassin en
semi ton sale est blanche et sa chemise
blanche vous vous enfermez dans votre
champ avec al jarreau barry white et
stevie wonder
c'est vrai que je crois que je me suis
chouchoutée est-ce que de 12 ans à 17
ans comme on le déjeuner était dure à
peu près un quart d'heure ce qui n'est
pas un pack plaisir donc on mange pour
manger quoi nous c'est à dire dix
minutes à tout casser un quart d'heure
et après donc jusqu'à jusqu'à la
sonnerie de l'école que j'entendais chez
moi c'est vrai je mettais tout c'est
voilà tout ça j'étais arrivé en classe
sous les c'est une drogue sous les
jeunes avec le sentait lésé ça pour ce
pauvre tenir le coup il y avait ça il
est le rire évidemment il ya paris il ya
peu d'un seul coup comme beaucoup
d'entre nous vous dites je vais monter à
paris parce que là où toute façon tout
est possible donc vous arrivez ici est
la première chose que vous faites en
arrivant on en voit bien là la fille de
marchand de chaussures qu'elle avait
marre de porter les pontes qu'on lui
faisait mais vous acheter des bottes et
des bottes magnifique c'est marrant je
sais exactement les votes pour faire
maintenant lui effet devises très pointu
sabine un vrai talent comme c'était plus
les modèles comme ça les talons de 10
centimètres pointu
bon j'étais très embêté d'aller pour la
première fois dans un et je me souviens
j'ai laissé un pourboire l'a fait parce
que vend des chaussures c'est pas vendre
les renvois que c'est difficile tu vas
acheter des chaussures ils sont
insupportables et jean faure fait mal
aux pieds les aime pas la couleur elles
sont trop longues à sa porte
ride ni
machin on y va pour se baisser et ses
cartons sa chambre sinon quelques
indices mais avoue le pied non ça me
gêne vraiment trompé mes parents alors à
paris vous arrivez le court durant pour
préparer le conservatoire elle est reçue
première à l'entrée du conservatoire et
l'az et michel bouquet comme prof c'est
pas mal hein c'est mieux que ça avait de
la chance il est d'essence et là vous
travaillez l'aiglon agrippine ce qui
fait que finalement quand on quand on
vous voit dans marilyn les gens ont
l'impression que c'est comme ça le truc
qui vous a pris un jour
j'arrête de faire de la scène je vais
faire du cinéma en fait vous avez
commencé comme ça alors est ce que
finalement le comique ça a été une
parenthèse mais c'est incroyable cette
histoire vous êtes parti là non on va
voir comment s'est jamais pensé moi je
vais là dit tiens je veux partir de
chacun pour faire ça c'est pas sais pas
et je me suis retrouvé quand même à
faire ça on m'aurait dit ça va durer 12
ans j'aurais dit mais comment
parce que je devais faire donc je vais
rater plein de trucs donc j'étais dans
la dans le voyage et comme voilà dans
ces familles ou si je commence pour en
finir ce qu'il a commencé tout ça c'est
pas des paroles c'est bien ce qu'ils ont
créé agressif de faire autrement
et alors là il ya un truc que difficile
à comprendre pourquoi c'est un coup de
blues à la fin du conservatoire pourquoi
vous rentrez pas dans une troupe de
théâtre
vous partez à saint-etienne revendre des
chaussures ça s'est un peu voilà tout
d'être dur le jour vous êtes reparti non
non c'est de rester correct et non et là
je vais en amérique centrale
mais comment tout seul non je m'arrêtais
un ami que je dis bouche avec un sac à
dos et voilà et on part pour deux mois
et je me dis ben voilà et quand je
reviens je veux dire voilà ça la vie
c'est ça ouais donc tu vas travailler un
peu faire tout temps chaud et tous les
ans tu partiras deux mois c'est à dire
de moi on ne regarde plus la date on y
vont rentrer dans une semaine on oui le
temps est complètement s'étant 80 je ne
vais plus jamais ça
le produit tout ça c'est vrai que cette
fois ça peut tomber sous les palmiers en
doute lundi c'est ça ouais on dit
toujours que la vie c'est ça qu'on
reçoit pamiers c'est faux pas par contre
souvent ou pas et là on retourne
reprenez à tout à zéro avec roger louret
les baladins en agenais bouvard le petit
théâtre mais rencontre énorme avec
pierre palmade évidemment on a vu ce que
ça a donné
bedos et puis là voilà vous fait une
carrière que complètement rien à voir
avec ce qui aurait dû être la vente
parce qu'au départ votre première
vocation c'est la musique et après vous
auriez dû faire du théâtre cela me fait
du one man show incroyable tout seul sur
scène mais vous dites au fond je me sens
comédienne faisait cette phrase qui est
très gentil je me sens plus proches de
suzanne flon que patrick bosso je fais
sont plus proches louis de suzanne flon
on voulait faire des vacances à leur
main d'oeuvre qui a beaucoup cité
je t'avais
ça va